when we do a double inhale so I'll do
this now twice through my nose you could
do it through your mouth but it works
best for your nose it's inhale
and then you sneak a little bit more air
in at the very end when you do that you
re-inflate those little sacks and when
you exhale then you discard all the
carbon dioxide at once so the simple way
to describe this protocol is that unless
you are under water you do a double
inhale followed by an extended exhale
and you offload the maximum amount of
carbon dioxide and we found in our
laboratory that just one two or three of
those physiological size brings your
level of stress down very very fast